hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
we're back on apex legends again today
we have some interesting stuff to talk
about a potential duo solo six man 24:12
man game modes and a bunch of bots
coming in the game as well so lots of
info that was just been leaked so it's
always like to me if you do enjoy
discography new I cover the
informational side of apex legends that
being the leaks the updates the new
events the new characters all that stuff
so you want to be kept up to date with
everything happening in the world of
apex legends just say subscribe to the
channel with that let's get started so
as always credit to gaming Intel for
reporting on this but as always credit
to apex game info which is the main
behind most of these leaks that have
been coming out in the past couple days
but it's no secret that a lot of the
players want to have a solo duo or some
type of quads game-mode I personally to
me I like the trio's mode I like that
it's only that but some people that come
from fortnight or pub G or any game that
has the solo basically all battle
Royales have that solo ability a lot of
people like to play alone so real quick
just based off the article it says that
the men who goes by the name of apex
game info has since managed to discover
a host of other leagues via in the game
files the biggest of which suggests apex
legends will soon have a 6 12 and 24 man
squads albeit implementing these changes
would seem very strange if we were to go
by this information it's likely that
respawn is going to be following suit
from fortnight we're epic games
introduced game modes like teams of 20
and 50 b54 apex legends it's likely that
a six man squad on the game of files are
referring to teams of 10
whereas 12 is teams of 5 and 24 is teams
of 3 that is of course depending on
whatever the player count for apex
Legends is in the near future there is
also a screenshot and I'm not going to
show this on screen not because I don't
want to give credit to them but just in
case of copyright issues I don't want to
get copyright strike down the video but
in the codes it does say a few things it
says duos and quotation marks as well
saying to man's staging unlimited three
men ground unlimited six men Kings
Canyon 12 man Kings Canyon 24 Kings
Canyon 12 man classic 12 man wall run
jump kit solo recruit and then recruit
and in solo now these are most likely
ideas that that the team has for example
the solo probably just means a solo game
mode 8 duo's is a duo game mode whereas
the 12 men we're at the classical wall
run jump kids solo and recruit is most
likely going to be multiple different
gamemodes maybe they're gonna have a
classic 12 man then maybe 12 men what
wall run is then you're gonna have the
ability to wall run but in teams of 12
the jump kit maybe you can jump higher
and do double jumps the solo maybe it's
a 12 man but everyone's on their own
kind of team I really don't know how
that's going to work but then it seems
like the six in the 12 in the 24 men are
pretty obvious because that is Kings
Canyon which is the name of the map in
Apex legends so it seems like there's
gonna be six man squads 12 and 24 squads
maybe coming in the near future I think
that'd be pretty interesting to see
especially considering how many
Ultimates and abilities that each of the
characters has in all their different
combos I can only imagine running into a
team of like 12 people for them playing
Gibraltar launching all of their
Ultimates and you can't even move an
inch because they're covering the entire
area just some absolute chaos especially
when it comes to the end of the circle I
think that'd be really interesting to
see now I know I doubt this is going to
be a fully fledged actual game-mode this
might just be one of those event game
modes I call fortnight has done in the
past just to maybe test a few things and
maybe add some stuff in the future but I
still think running around at the end of
the circle with like 12 on 12 with
everyone's Ultimates out I think that'd
be pretty crazy and kind of interesting
to see how that would work on top of
this though there was also leaks about
bots being leaked it says furthermore
the 6 to 12 and 24 men squads weren't
the only thing mentioned in the data
mined in the game's files alongside
information about squad bots they also
seem to feature although if the data
mines are anything to go by they might
appear to only be in the 12 to 24 man
game modes but not the 6 main game mode
now I'm not really sure what they mean
by BOTS maybe this is what they're gonna
do for solo and duo where you can
actually play alone and but you I have
to play in a team of 3 and then the
other two are bots or if soul is gonna
be its own mode where everyone's alone
no matter if there's no BOTS or not I
really don't know what the whole plan is
on how they're even gonna implement bots
in this game I could understand if maybe
you're in a team of two and you're
trying to play trio you and you don't
want to like fill up with a random guy
just want a box the two you're going
that's completely fine I really don't
know how else is going to fit especially
in these 6 12 and 24 men game modes I
really don't understand what the bots
would mean but let me know your thoughts
of that guys in the comments below I'd
love to know your thoughts yeah it's
gonna be the end of the vid today guys
hope you guys did enjoy
like I said in like two minutes ago not
even 5 seconds ago let me know your
thoughts on everything that we talked
about what the bots you think what
purpose they'll serve within the game
thoughts on a solo duo six men 12 man 24
men
mode coming to the game do you think
they'll just be like kind of like events
where they only come and go or do you
think the solo in duo are going to stay
within the game for the rest of it or
maybe it's a test run for them in their
thoughts with that like the V if you do
enjoy subscriber for new I covered the
informational side of apex legends that
being the updates the balance changes
the leaks the new game modes the new
legends anything like that as well as
producing tips and guides about apex
legends to make sure everyone has caught
up to date with the with what is
happening within the game so if you
never want to miss out on a single
update definitely stay subscribe to the
channel and with that guys my two most
recent videos would be on-screen if you
guys do want to check that out with that
guy so ever-greater sterday thank you
for watching the video and peace out
enjoy the rest of your day
[Music]